people that i hired and i hired a few
hundreds of people in the past
decade and i built multiple marketing
organizational structures
i never looked on where they studied i'm
always i prefer to have
a failing entrepreneur marketing
entrepreneur in my team rather than you
know someone from an ivy league sorry if
i'm
hurting someone uh but that's my
perspective
as i told these are the scars that i got
on my face
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
i am joined by one of israel's leading
marketing executives
yam regev vp of marketing at elementor
yam has 15 years of experience in
driving breakthrough marketing that
grows company's profile profit and pride
at scale his company's zest was recently
acquired by walkme
and he is now the vp of marketing at
elementor this episode was recorded
before he sold zest
and before he announced his joining to
elementor
please enjoy welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
yo thanks for having me buddy it's great
to have you i'm excited to talk about
chief marketing officer i'm excited to
talk about your endeavors your
incredible journey and
i've read numerous articles that you've
written about the journey of of a cmo
and the challenges behind it the burnout
behind it but also the really exciting
pieces
and as a really non-marketing guy myself
i can't wait to learn and extract as
much knowledge and information and
experience from you
yum take me all the way back why are you
a marketing expert why
what is it about it that excites you
yeah you know that's
that's a huge question i think my mother
asked me the same the same
one and i don't have the perfect answer
of course
but i think that what i what i
discovered about myself is that i can
understand
how to put it in english you know it's
like the psychology and the biology
behind the human thinking if that makes
sense
and i think that's something that i
always had the the the orientation
a fall and eventually um
you know a few huge things needed to
happen in my life so
you know they will leave me here but um
i felt that i'm like being a
um not direct but um attracted
to the marketing field we can say um
because i understood it we can
influence the way people think in a good
way
in a sleazy way in whatever kind of way
but it's something that um you know to
have some sort of influence or impact
on how people think and then what they
can do with themselves
make better a better version of
themselves um i think it's something
that really um that's what makes me
wake up every morning in my marketing
life of course
and to say all right i'm doing something
fun that something can be um that can
help a lot of
other people and i can um i can leverage
it to my
myself and i can also you know make sure
that others can
uh can understand it and appreciate it
eventually
and how easy is it to differentiate
between a good marketer and a bad
marketer or a good cmo
versus a not so good cmo yeah
you know probably each cmo will tell you
something different i i really
pushing an agenda that i call that the
cmos need to be cemos like chief empathy
and marketing officers i think that
these days especially now with the
pandemic and all
we all should put the people that we uh
the people that we lead
um to be you know the first touch point
in everything that we do
so the people that we lead can be our
teams can be them
by our employees can be people that we
work with people that we work
under users customers whatever
all those you know all the all the
humans that they under our
responsibilities we need to make sure
that they are not feeling under pressure
we are all experiencing some you know
um you can say um tectonic plates right
as we said before that are
shifting around us and it's our
obligation to make sure
that those people that work with us for
us and
of course using our products we feel
secure
we feel that no one is bluffing them and
um and we feel that
they're doing something that support a
bigger cause
not just to buy something or to make
something better but
to have an actual impact on what we do i
think that that's an obligation of each
leader not not not necessarily if it's a
marketing leader
or an engineer leader or whatever it's
our obligation to make sure that we're
having some good impact on the world or
the micro world you know around us
i love it so you're talking about the
tectonic movements which the word
tectonic you know it implies that you
know big big movements big shifts
that you have and you mentioned to me
also that you have some pretty big
shifts going on with you and i can
you know just by looking at your journey
i can imagine that there were quite a
few of these big tectonic shifts that
you've done
as you've progressed through the various
cmo positions
through the different advisory positions
board positions so yeah
walk me through some of the big
highlights where you really you know
have gotten you know either comfortable
or uncomfortable with these experiences
what have you learned over the scope of
your career until now
about the art of influencing about the
art of marketing
with empathy being in the forefront
which i can see that it's a primary
it's a primary consideration for you
right so
you know there are a lot of learning
from from the past i think the time
in the industry we can say for the past
15 years and of course i
i wrote um not too many hats but
so many ads right so as you said i um i
was also a
solo entrepreneur and i managed a web
marketing agency that go to be a huge
operation and then i was marketing
executive in a growth stage startup and
then i
i went to be a co-founder in a company
that i co-founded with
with a good friend and a colleague and
um and now i'm doing advisory and then
part of a lot of
startups say both so you know i'll try
to to
distill but still to distill what i
learned but again
um i'm 100 mistake
in what i do and what i'm going to tell
ever to tell you because
it's only about my experience and
knowledge so no one should copy paste it
or use it as is just you know take it
with a lot of grain of salt and adapt it
to whatever your needs are
but i think that um eventually what i
understood
is that um i need i need to constantly
learn and improve i i think that as
profession as a professional or as
professionals
we are committed to three things to grow
our network to go to grow our
knowledge and to grow our experience
right those are the three pillars that i
believe every entrepreneur or every
leader
or every professional um they have
in their professional personality we can
say
if i try to grow one of those pillars
more than the more than the other let's
say i will just keep on learning
theoretical stuff
so probably the platforms of the
leadership the platform of the
literature that i will lay on it will be
you know
on the side and it will just slide over
so i think that we all we should be very
um um uh we could say um
what do you call it like um to make sure
that we are going to three pillars
um evenly and in order to do so of
course each pillar can see
comprised from micro different pillars
um
in our you know in our journey so i
think that i
you know in one of those pillars that i
call um knowledge and
and network i discovered that each week
i need to meet
with at least two people that i define
as 10x
than me they can be deaf better
marketers they can be there for
entrepreneurs they can be better
brand managers they can be better
professionals you know whatever whatever
i will define them as 10x
than me i know that i need to read or to
listen or to watch
for at least one piece of content each
each day you know i'm blocking time on
my calendar
for that sometimes i'm just copy pasting
even the link to what i'm going to watch
listen or
read to the to the title of the calendar
invite of myself of course um and then i
i know that i cannot run over this meet
this it's a meeting right it's waiting
for
for for for everything so i need to
respect it
um and the other thing is about
experience i think that experience
um it's been underestimated in a lot of
places i'm i'm
totally dyslexic um i cannot you will
not find me and right i cannot i cannot
even close
a circle with with a pen um you will not
find me
standing by a white board and drawing
stuff on my team that i'm leading
i cannot do that my barely finished
school
i didn't i was a college or university
dropout
so i i i the people that i hired and i
hired a few hundreds of people in the
past
decade and i built multiple marketing
organizational structures
i never looked on where they started i'm
always i prefer to have
a failing entrepreneur or marketing
entrepreneur in my team rather than
you know someone from an ivy league so
if i'm hurting someone
but that's my perspective as i told
these are the scars that i got on my
face um
so i believe you know if i try to
actionize
what i just said i would say go ahead
and fail
start try to fail do something that will
just increase your
experience even if you will not be
successful but you will understand how
things works what does it mean to be a
leader how to be an
entrepreneur what does it mean to um to
build a startup for instance or to build
a marketing organizational structure or
whatever just go ahead and do so
i i really appreciate those kind this
kind of approach this is how i build my
own
uh professionality we can say uh when
i'm breaking it down to those three
pillars
so with that with that failure in mind
are there common things that you're
observing over your over the span of
your career working with marketers
things that you're just saying you know
it just doesn't work
this tactic or this idea or this
influencing tactic either doesn't work
in the long run or doesn't fulfill
really the requirements because one of
the things that i've been trying to
think about is
how can i look back at journeys of
people that span over years
and try to see what are some things that
they can distill from their experience
that i simply can't you know without
that experience in my mind so what are
some things that you've been observing
in the marketing world that you're
saying michael just you know just don't
do this
don't make this mistake that i'm seeing
so many people make
and i'm not even a marketing guy but
i'll have to deal with marketing all
right
we have i told you that it's going to
happen right beautiful that's a part of
the show
come join us she got she got she got um
um um how do you call it right there
someone just said he
and she got the heat on her head with
another kid
so yeah she would join us probably for
the rest of the interview
what is her name often
nice to meet you welcome to our show yum
was just
your father yam was just about to tell
me some of the things that i should
avoid
as either i do marketing myself or that
the people that i work with will do
marketing for our products
right i think you know the bigger stuff
that you can think about it like um you
know never sell
if you'll try to sell something you will
never try it means that you're doing
sales and not marketing i think it's
very hard to do sales
without without do without doing
marketing so you know direct sale or a
hard sale
think it's something that it's like a
second wave of that tsunami
that you should do uh right after you're
undertaking a huge you know marketing
affairs
um so that's i think one of the one of
the main thing
the other thing is that you should know
that you never know nothing eventually
and the way that you will win your
leadership entrepreneurship or being a
good
marketing even leader or just a junior
someone it means that you need to have a
lot of brain power
with you and i'll give you an example in
some companies that i'm advising to 11
companies that i founded
so what we created quite early on even
if they were you know really small
and early early startups so we created
some sort of a user advisory board
for those startups right you need to
really understand what makes people dick
and stick and all that
that's for sure because no one will do
nothing for you but three reasons
either for fame money or good cause
right again it's number three i'm not
sure what's going on today with numbers
you know the number three but um and
those three things will
these are the only reasons people will
do something
for you so quite early on in many
startups you can
find probably you're not going to pay
people to do something for you because
then
you'll get a lot of you know it will be
a biased kind of feedback
but you can definitely um harness them
for a good cause
that they even if it's to help you or
your initiative or whatever
or your product is going to solve a big
pain so that's one thing and the other
thing is that you can always
fame them right in on social media you
we all the time talking about shaming
i'm talking about framing
so you know why not um yeah why not
giving you know um
posting um a beautiful post on social
media on linkedin let's say
if someone help you to i don't know to
think about something over
or to find you know a shorter way to do
um to you know to find your
user a feature feature user feed not
product market feed but
feature user fit so i think that that's
a that's that's one thing that you can
just harness a group of people
that they will function as your user
advisory board if even if those just
five people you know that they're
relevant for what you're doing for your
target audience
so um i think that's what i found as a
marketer
that it's good it's helped me a lot to
accelerate the process
of marketing even to ask them what is a
good unique value proposition to put on
my website what might
can you describe my what my solution can
can do for you what would be the feeling
so um i think that just you know having
people to think with you
especially these days when we are
working remotely and
we are not meeting each other and all
that so that's a nice hack
as a marketer that you can quickly you
know you can do it tomorrow you don't
need funds for that
you just need to create a process a
brief undertake it and you know
just manage it properly i love it it
reminds me a lot of rahul
of rahul's work from superhuman i
remember in one of my classes in
university we we took
superhuman as a case study in the first
round article that
discussed his journey to find the nps
score and how he created
his different user advisory boards but
he was very very intentional
with the types of users he was getting
and the questions he was asking them
and how to take people out of the board
and bring them in
because it sounds to me um that what
you're describing here it
you know it goes up and goes down based
on the quality of the people that you
bring
on board and and these need to either be
you know champions
or they need to be people who really
hate you and you need to understand why
and i think that's just wonderful and
yum i think that you know there's so
many more things that i want to talk
about your past but it sounds to me also
that
the things you're working on now are are
just as exciting
so tell me a little bit about where
you're doing today with
both your your own company but also on
the different endeavors that you're a
part of
right so yeah i'll i'll run through it
quite fast and because um
you know i don't want to self sell
myself but um
i'll just share my thoughts and feelings
of course as usual i think that um
i'm dividing my time right now um in
three again three
different um aspects um seventy percent
of my time i'm
advising to a a few golf stage startups
like
two not not few it's only only two only
two
um quite big operations uh so how
they'll go
we are thinking over how to scale the
operation for
um dozens of millions of uh in ir
to you know um hundreds of millions of
pharah
so that's 70 of my time 20 percent of my
time i am i'm
i'm leaving to work with buying startup
startups that um
raised up to 15 million dollars
over there i'm a little bit more and
hands-on
over there but not to end zone i i
discovered i'm not that good being
hands-on and maybe anymore or maybe i
was like that all the time i'm not sure
um but that's something that is very
important for me to stay
you know close to the whole cycle of you
know giving a birthday um
to a startup and then of course growing
it and scaling it and all that
so i find it good and then ten percent
of my time it's around the four to six
hours
each week i'm keeping to um help other
entrepreneurs and
and and marketing leaders and also uh
founders
uh so eventually um you know it's
something that i wish that i had when i
started off
and even now you know if someone um you
know
can help me or will help me or if i just
of course i'm as i said i'm consulting
with
two people that are next time that means
something something each week
so that's what i'm doing for others so
if someone is someone needs some
some sort of help with anything whether
it's marketing leadership
entrepreneurship whatever so i'd be
happy to have you know 30 minutes
conversation with them
um i i think that um like
mutual support is the new currency as
far as it relates to
um you know the principles that we need
to um
we can say to nurture you know the
society um i wish it was something that
was more rooted
in our thought process and the way that
we are speaking with each other the way
that we think about each other
um so that's something i'm trying to
bring you know to push
or to deliver my own agenda and i know
that once i will need
um a help and i'm sure that at some
given point i will need help
in you know in this way or the other i
hope that those people that i that i
contributed my time to
uh you know they will reach their end to
you to help me and i'm quite sure that
it will
it will pay off although again i'm not
doing it for being paid off i just think
it's the right way
to walk right and obviously it's a huge
butterfly effect
once you're doing it for somebody and
they do it for somebody else you can
imagine how that
how how that snowball gets bigger and
bigger with every duration
that that happens and i think that's
amazing tell me a little bit about zest
and what you're doing there you're very
active there and
and and you what we talk about now is
sort of making this impact
on on a scale of of of a few people
growing you know with the butterfly
effect but you're also working on
products that are making an
impact on on you know much larger scale
so what what are some of those
endeavors over there right so this right
now i'm uh i have more passive kind of
role i may i'm only a board member over
there my partner daniel which is leading
the company
with our team over there basically
the product knows we can say how to um
how to make information and knowledge
accessible across
teams times and tools so you can find
any kind of file or folder
or even um you know even an image on
photoshop
from wherever you are you don't need to
waste time in
searching in you know your databases and
and then that and in the
google drive and all those you know huge
places where we just throw in stuff
it's like um the smartest um
how do you call it the library library
man that work in the library how do you
call them
librarian brilliant right so
it's like the smallest librarian that
you can have but in a very
not a successful way also in a very a
proactive way so if you are starting to
write
let's say to compose an email on gmail
so then our ai
knows they're starting to understand the
context and the the
people that you're going to send the
email to so then it knows
how to uh proactively ask you or to let
you know that you probably need to
attach this file or this folder
to your email without you even thinking
about it so it's like
you know grammarly for the enterprise
that knows how to
recommend you file folders and whatever
you need to send
in order to make your job much easier
and then you don't need to waste a lot
of time on searching those stuff
as well you can just search and serve
them on this where in the unified
you'll find a cell so it works that way
we work with
you know quite big organizations these
days it's a very exciting
kind of operation we started from
scratch and you know it's it's beautiful
to see this
uh this you know this baby walk alone so
that's
really great i love it yum
first of all thank you for coming and
spending your time with me i just loved
it
and you know 20 minutes go by way way
too fast it's just unbelievable
and but i do have the most important
question that i have to ask you which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
three words all right so um
uh there is there is a branding
methodology that i developed few i think
it was like two years ago when we just
launched the zest
and we call it the the vat vat
methodology it means vulnerability
potency authenticity and transparency
and i think that we developed it
together of course you know the whole
team um it's something that really um
i think that reflect the way that i'm
being active or being open on social
media but not only there also
you know with my family and friends and
and all that i um you not see me
wearing masks and trying to be you know
this important guy or
or whatever you'll just you know what
you see is what you get
um so i think that those three words uh
and this and the abbreviation i think
it's something that really reflect the
way
i'm i i am in life in my professional
life in my personal life
so and i think it's i would love to see
more leaders
uh taking this kind of approach and
being more transparent and being more
vulnerable but i think it's just and of
course being more authentic i i think
it's
just being more as we said empathetic
human
so i really appreciate this kind of
approach and i know that i'm being
attracted or connected with uh with
like-minded
entrepreneurs and marketing leaders that
take the same kind of approach
and i i would like to see more people
taking this kind of approach just being
open shall you know that shallow
information with others
uh if you understand that um you know
i'm a big success comprised from a
a wall of a fellow bricks and success
bricks
right so that's that that's how i feel
that you can build uh oh this is
the way that i'm building success so i
think that um
um you will not be afraid to fail now
there is a nice post that i posted on
linkedin back then that said you know
let's fail together whether it was
back then it was when with my um vp of
marketing that i told her let's fail
together i'm i'm behind you let let's do
that
it will be a great fellow but we'll do
it together we learn so much from that
and the success will come right after
and it came so that's something
important to take to take you know to
take away the next item from this
interview i i can't imagine the you know
the excitement and the relief at the
same time of somebody within an
organization where there are leaders
coming and saying let's fail together
and we're welcoming this this is an
approach and i think that that's that's
very inspiring for me and
and i'm going to have to credit you
whenever i i start doing that hopefully
when i when i lead a team myself
thank you very very much i wish your
your daughter a very very quick recovery
i know how much it hurts i remember it
from the playground myself
and thank you for joining me today i
really appreciate it and i can't wait to
share with the world thank you
it was a real pleasure a pleasure thank
you so much for having me
thank you bye
[Music]